In my last rant all about the ridiculousness it takes just to write a simple
sentence in Japanese,
the list of complications kept growing and growing and growing until we threw
that Kaji bomb under the mix,
like a writing systems Ninja,
but I didn't even get into the stuff that really takes Japanese Kanji over the
top,
making them seriously awkward.
Don't forget,
don't you dare forget that Japan borrowed it's characters from China.
That's important because it explains what happens next.
When a con g came on the boat across the seat,
it brought its Chinese pronunciation along with it.
But Chinese and Japanese are two very different languages with two very
different pronunciations systems.
So each character didn't get pronounced the way somebody from China would say
it,
but the way it's somebody from Japan would hear it.
Here's how I imagine that history.
Well,
hello,
who might you be hot?
Okay,
con no hun.
Yes,
gun.
Nice to meet you con.
And that is just the tip of the support or ice sculpture.
What makes this confusing cultural mismatch even better is that the acoustic
exchange happened a long time ago.
So it's the way characters from old China sounded to people in old Japan and
since like I explained last time,
most characters are a bad game of charades with one part of the character
telling you what the word sounds like.
The confusion coming out of this phonological telephone game mix.
That vague sounds like hint,
even more vague and Japanese.
The fancy term for this cultural mishmash of Kaji pronunciation is the Sino
Japanese reading.
In Japanese,
they call it the literally sound reading,
which makes sense.
It's your reading the Kanji with its Chinese sound and of course there's more
than one way to skin and on Naomi there's goal.
That's the classical Wu pronunciation of the characters from the fifth century.
Then came the condom,
which are Tang dynasty pronunciation starting in the seventh century,
Dole and pronunciations made their way to Japan from the later dynasties.
The final O'Neil me is gone.
Your outlier pronunciations and even mistakes that became conventional and stuck
around over the centuries.
So yeah,
don't be surprised when the own Naomi for a Kanji you're learning is actually a
bunch of different Sino Japanese pronunciations.
This has amusing consequences.
If you go to zen ceremonies,
they recite this passage in classical Chinese.
It's called the heart sutra,
but this is Japan and these are all Kanji.
So how do you think the suture gets pronounced?
In classical Chinese?
No,
in standard Chinese?
in Japanese,
no,
it's just chanted as a long string of O'neil.
Me basically resulting in jibberish in both languages conjure.
You don't just have on your me though.
They also have,
like I said before,
Japanese and Chinese are two very different languages,
which means that all of these own yeoman getting borrowed century after century
are basically foreign vocabulary words.
But do you think the native Japanese words just stepped aside and made room for
all the shiny new Chinese terms?
No.
The incoming Kanji had to fit Japanese to Japanese words got matched to Chinese
characters.
It seemed like a good fit at the time.
Here is the character for cart or vehicle.
It has a few Sino Japanese when Yo me,
but the basic one is shot,
but the Japanese already had a word for this.
Good Houma.
So this character can represent any of these pronunciations.
It wasn't an exact science though.
Just like you can have multiple Chinese pronunciations for each Kanji.
Why not have multiple Japanese meaning readings too?
There's even one more bunch of readings to add to this list downloading.
It's for proper names and it's usually yet another native Japanese pronunciation
for the character and the excitement doesn't stop there.
Domato cheap because it's time to forget the reading.
Fun and think about all the writing fun you could have with these.
That is where you really get to play with this systems within systems madness,
I mean a amazingness.
That is the conduit.
If you really want to play fast and loose with the history and meaning of these
characters,
you can switch in some [inaudible].
Those are Kanji characters used just for the way they sound.
When you see Sushi written this way,
that's some Improv at Digi stuff going on.
Neither of those characters is anything to do with the meaning of that word.
Sometimes Japan just builds its own characters following the logic of Chinese
character composition just makes characters up because you can be productive
with this charades game.
These are called [inaudible] country characters.
Sometimes there are newer ways,
an older ways of writing the exact same character gene,
gene QG dying.
Sometimes a character gets way too complicated or you're just feeling creative
and you need to abbreviate it and one way or another,
and by abbreviate,
I mean turn it into a completely unrecognizable thing that I'll sit there trying
to look up like,
what is that?
It wasn't all my official Kaji list.
Yeah.
Could you and mastering one character is only a fraction of the battle.
Often characters don't mean what you think they mean,
or they really don't mean much on their own.
Japanese loves to combine characters to make a word.
You go Japan stack those characters,
and then once you're comfortable with Multicom g words level up again to tackle
those terse little three character or for character proverbs that pack some deep
meaning in just a very few syllables.
This is not even where things get out of hand.
I promise you.
You see,
it's not the quirky syllables from last time.
It's not the quagmire that you get into when you start memorizing all the Kanji
with their sound ratings.
There meaning readings.
There's substitutions and abbreviations.
It's the untamed beast that only rears its head when you first put eat to that
fresh sheet of Japanese paper,
which looks a lot like regular paper.
Stop and think about how super intricate the characters get with all their
little lines and strokes and dash.
Well,
I tell you in all seriousness that there's officially a right way and a wrong
way to write each and every single mark in these things.
You made it this far,
but I need you next time to help me through this.
Stick around and subscribe for language.